unfortunately i have some very sad news
i can confirm that our specialist police
search and rescue team
who were continuing to search the storm
drain complex
recovered the body of a young male in
the north belfast area
just before 9 45 a.m
today while we have no official
identification
we do believe it is the missing teenager
noah donahoe
our thoughts and sympathies are with
noah's family
and we're continuing to provide support
to them
at this very difficult and heartbreaking
time
it is disappointing that i again need to
comment about people
circulating a number of rumors about
noah's disappearance
which are completely without foundation
this type of commentary and rumor is
distressing for noah's family
and is extremely unhelpful
an investigation into the circumstances
of noah's disappearance
is still continuing but there is no
evidence
to suggest foil play
again i would like to thank everyone who
has helped conduct
and participate in the searches for noah
over the last
few days i also want to thank
everyone who contacted the police with
information
thank you
you